shooting already
we get you nice and comfy hello I am Bob
DeSimone director of the McGovern
Institute at MIT welcome to do not
tonight's discussion which is
co-sponsored with the Alfred P sloan
foundation it is stimulated by the new
PBS series brains on trial at the
intersection of neuroscience and the law
which could not be a more timely topic
given the events of the last couple days
are the host of the series and our host
tonight is Alan Alda the seven-time Emmy
award-winning actor writer director
myself and I'm sure most of you here
first became acquainted with Alan in the
hit television show mash of course about
the mobile army field hospital in the
Korean War Alan not only starred in the
series but he also wrote and directed
many of the episodes he also wrote two
best-selling books including what I
overheard when I was talking to myself
starred in many subsequent TV shows
movies but maintained his interest in
medicine I guess having been through the
medical war and and what became an
effective communicator of science he was
the host of the scientific american
frontier series he won an award from the
national science board for his public
service and communicating science to the
public and we here at the McGovern
Institute feel we have a special
connection to Alan Alan spoke at our
anniversary event in 2010 he came at the
end of a long line of scientists
speakers like myself who used the time
to present data on our slides and so on
and then in Alan's presentation he got
up and he told us scientists that if he
wanted to effectively communicate about
our science we should ditch all those
slides and just learn how to talk
effectively to people and of course is
being highly trained scientists we
ignore that advice but I am proud to say
I have gotten through this entire
introduction without a single data slide
I know fantastic Bravo but you could
have shown a picture of one of miami's I
give you Alex thank you Bob thank you
very much thank you thank you all for
coming tonight and thanks to the
McGovern Institute and to Bob DeSimone
the director for having us here tonight
and here's what it's about for the last
couple of years Graham Chad and I have
been working on a two-part special for
PBS which is which concerns itself with
the implications for the justice system
of the ability of brain signs now to
peer into people's brains bringing
together those two disciplines that up
until now seemed far apart and now are
very close together increasingly close
together in any case the first show is
last Wednesday night tomorrow night will
be the second show and just to give you
an idea of what the program is like and
what our conversation will be based on
I'd like to run you a clip from the
beginning of the second episode could we
could we see that clip hello I'm Alan
Alda this is the courthouse in lower
Manhattan where we've been filming the
trial of a young man accused of the
all-too-common crime of robbing a
convenience store robbery that in this
case turned into a tragedy
startled by the sudden appearance of the
store owner's wife Jimmy Moran fired a
shot that left her with a grievous brain
injury the crime is fictitious all right
we'll call the case of people vs. Moran
but during the emotional trial of the
character Jimmy Moran the case was
argued before a very real and
distinguished federal judge by
practicing attorneys the defendant Jimmy
Moran is holding his gun everything that
happens here happens in a matter of less
than 10 seconds during the course of
filming the trial we took breaks from
the courtroom to explore how
neuroscience in particular the ability
to look into people's heads with
powerful brain scanning machines may one
day be employed in a real trial we saw
how brain scans could potentially reveal
whether someone has told a lie I want to
find out if I did I do whether an
eyewitness remembers a face or if a
defendant has the crime scene etched in
his brain has the jury reached a verdict
yes your honor our trial concluded his
first phase with the jury clearing Jimmy
Moran of attempted murder but finding
him guilty of armed robbery and
aggravated assault the jury's job is
done now it's up to the judge to decide
on the punishment that fits the crime
how much blame should Jimmy take for
what it did how responsible is he for
the devastating brain injury because
what does he deserve judges are already
beginning to turn to bring science for
answers to these questions in our
fictional case we'll see how that
science is providing unprecedented
insights into the minds of young people
like our defendant and why his age is
troubled childhood even the mere
presence of his friends can all conspire
to push him into foolish and reckless
acts
let me introduce our panelists to you
first our host Bob DeSimone Bob is the
director of the McGovern Institute and
the professor in mi T's department of
brain and cognitive cognitive science
from 2008 to 2010 he served as network
co-director of the macarthur law and
neuroscience project Nancy kanwisher
when Bob's left was a founding member of
the McGovern Institute and also a
professor at MIT s department of brain
and cognitive science the kanwisher lab
uses brain imaging the study the
functional organization of the human
brain Josh green is from next door at
Harvard where he's associate professor
professor of the Social Sciences in the
psychology department is research
focuses on the interplay of emotion and
reasoning in moral decision-making he's
also been a valuable advisor to our
brings on trial project since the
beginning baya luna is professor of
psychiatry at the University of
Pittsburgh School of Medicine where she
directs the laboratory of neurocognitive
development as you'll see a little later
she leads research projects exploring
impulsivity and adolescence as well as
the occasional older visitor like me
Stephen Morris is professor of law
professor of psychology and associate
director of the Center for neuroscience
and society at the University of
Pennsylvania he was instrumental in
building the MacArthur law and
neuroscience project so let's get to the
first topic folks it's it's maybe the
most one of the most controversial
questions in the interface of the law
and neuroscience the question of whether
or not brain imaging can tell if
somebody is lying we went on the show we
went out to an MRI facility in
Framingham where there is a company
called Cephas it was marketing MRI lie
detection
and I got in there scanner and the idea
was to find out if they could tell if I
was lying and not just to determine if
they could do it but to see how it
worked what what's the process they go
through how do they try to determine if
you're lying or not so I was left alone
in a room and I was told to take from a
drawer either a ring or a watch here's
what happened the ring or the watch
I'm really tempted to take them both is
the ring in your locker no did you take
the ring no did you steal the ring no
was the ring stolen no did you hide the
ring no did you steal next came a
practice session when I honed my skill
at denying everything which of course
meant that half the time I'm lying did
you put the ring in your locker no did
you leave the ring in the drawer yes did
the ring stay in the drawer yes was the
ring move from the drawer not by me did
you hide the watch in your locker no did
you remove a watch from the drawer no do
you steal a watch from the drawer I'm
gonna get a rubber hose you know let's
go much faster this right here is now
it's time for the brain scan the keypad
will allow me to answer yes or no as the
questions are projected onto a screen
above my face while I'm in the scanner
you get the pleasure at seeing my brain
revealed this is a structural scam but
once the questions start coming the
machine will be making repeated scans to
see how different parts of my brain are
responding as I answer this type of
brain scan is called a functional MRI
and it's the key technology will be
encountering as we explore how neuro
scientists are probing breams the
scanner creates images of multiple
slices through the brain picking out
regions were a cluster of nerve cells
among the several billion in the brain
is working especially hard
harder working cells need more blood to
fuel them this extra blood flowing
through the nest of capillary
surrounding the nerve cells generates a
magnetic signal and it's this signal an
indirect measure of nerve cell activity
that the fMRI machine detects and
displays what do you think I took out of
the drawer their computer made the
determination that she took the ring
uh-huh you want to find out if I did I
do all right very good I feel like a
little relieved i think i should point
out that a few months after we filmed
this show Steve lakin stopped offering
fMRI lie detection in his company I
don't know why he stopped but I think at
least one member of our panel is really
happy he did you Nancy you you made your
feelings really clear on the show about
that kind of effort to determine if
somebody's lying using a brain scan what
how do you feel about this test well I
think it doesn't really work I think it
may be that some day with advances that
we can't imagine now it's remotely
possible that would happen but right now
nobody has shown anything even remotely
close to real lie detection so what
they've shown is in probably what he
picked up on on this scan is that if you
ask people to say something that's not
true versus something that's true it
takes a little bit more mental effort to
say something that's not true and so
that produces very systematic
activations in the brain they can be
replicated there's extra mental activity
but it's not diagnostic mental activity
if he had done this experiment and said
we think that you took that ring and we
were going to test and find out if you
are innocent or not and and what we're
going to do is we're going to find out
if you respond differentially during
that time so in other words if you were
suspected and if a lot was at stake
it's quite possible all of the same
brain activity would happen so he would
he the way he's doing this with me is is
in a highly controlled environment I
didn't really steal anything as a matter
of fact that was my ring in my watch so
it wasn't it wasn't even a question of
determining if I was guilty of an act
that I could perhaps go to jail for was
really just looking at the brain
activity while I was supposedly lying
exactly and so you know for this to be
of any use at all in the real world you
need to test it under those
circumstances that could make all the
difference in brain scanning that is
major stakes not 50 boxes in a
psychology experiment but life in prison
right and you need to test it where the
person at the time of the scanning
believes that this scan could determine
their fate you'd need to actually have a
gold standard of whether to determine
later whether they were telling the
truth or not I can't imagine how you'd
ever do that experiment actually you do
scams similar to the but what are you
looking for in the brain and why are you
doing the hands the most relevant
experiment addresses precisely the issue
that Nancy raised and if anything raises
further doubts about the interpretation
behind the method that lakin is using so
one of Nancy's many excellent points is
that you weren't really lying you were
you were saying something false under
the instruction of the experimenter but
that's a really big distinction eyes on
the very big this thing I mean he told
me to not tell the trays right so it did
would we expect something different to
happen in my brains though because I'm
not deliberately lying right yeah so so
I and Joe Paxton in my lab did an
experiment in which people told realize
and it wasn't life-and-death stakes but
it was it they were at least realized
and our setup was like this we are
having people predict the outcomes of
these electronic coin flips and they got
money if they could predict correctly
and they lost money if they couldn't
predict correctly and sometimes they had
to record their prediction in advance
okay heads and then they get their money
or not dip
ending on whether they turn out to be
right in another condition in the same
experiment we said you know what you
don't have to tell us in advance what
your prediction is just tell us
afterwards whether or not you got it
right and will trust you sort of like
playing tennis and you have to decide if
it was inside or outside so I say all
right light with a lot of social so it's
up to you and we had a cover story we're
interested in people's ability to
predict the future and if some people
think that if you have to tell people
what your prediction is that it ruins it
and so keeping it okay well that sounds
very plausible a few people were
suspicious and we got rid of them hi
it's very important experiment and and
so that so then we've so now we can look
at the people who when they have the
opportunity to lie some people are right
at fifty percent where they should be if
they have no magical powers and other
people are sixty seventy five percent
getting close to a hundred percent so we
have a even though on any given trial we
don't know if someone said oh I guessed
heads and I was right well maybe they
did but in aggregate for a given person
we can see are they are ganna getting
too many of these right to be credible
so we can sort people into the people
who are very clearly Ryung people who
show no sign of lying the people who are
in the middle and so now we've got this
group of people who are almost certainly
lying there there the odds that they
would do as well as they're doing by
chance are one in a thousand or even
worse and so the question is what goes
on in those people well it turns out
that the same part of the brain roughly
speaking that that CFS is focusing on
the kind is reliably activated when
people make a special effort to do
something and this can be remembering a
phone number or anything like that
prefrontal control network is what it's
sometimes called we saw a lot of
activity in the prefrontal control
network in these people more than in the
other group but we saw as much activity
there when they claimed the win often
falsely versus when they let one go and
said you know I could lie here but I'm
not going so the effort to decide
whether or not you're going to lie to
maybe hold yourself back from lying or
make the decision to go ahead and do it
and evaluate what the risks are all of
that causes prefrontal cortex level of
cognitive effort and in the tiny little
controlled experiment that you
participated in it may genuinely be the
case that
saying and instructed fall so it takes a
little more effort than saying the truth
now in a more realistic situation not
fully realistic but one where you're
really lying and there really is
something if not everything at stake we
don't see that distinction so they were
they looking in the same places do you
think we are roughly yes yeah Bob Bob
what what do you think if this is not
really going to be able to tell us if
someone is lying or not is there am a
higher more important bit of knowledge
to be gained from this about how the
brain works about how to bring
cooperates and decision-making and that
kind of thing oh these are all very
valid basic research questions about
control processes how you you know how
you use networks to make one kind of
response that may not be your automatic
response how you make a non automatic
responses are all very very valid
questions in the field they're just not
directed at whether someone's lying or
not this very practical practical
question we learned a tremendous amount
in cognitive neuroscience from these
kinds of cognitive near iment sabrine
networks function so there's no
scientists don't have any problem with
this kind of research it's only its use
that you know people and and yet it
seems Stephen it seems to be there seems
to be a movement toward bringing this
into the courtroom am I wrong well not
so much for the question of why
detection that has come up basically in
to decided cases and in both cases the
judge rejected the use of the evidence
for that purpose on the ground that well
did that stop the effort to bring lie
detection with MRI into the courtroom or
is it still attempted we don't have very
good evidence for that right now
nationwide my guess is since both of
these decisions were very clear that it
wasn't ready for prime time my guess is
it did put a brake on it the real
question is whether it's being used more
for culpability types of decisions or
prediction types of decisions in what
way what do you mean by then well a
culpability decision would be
help us decide whether someone is guilty
or not or what their state of mind was
at the time of a crime a prediction
question might be can you use a brain
scan or some sort of neuro marker to add
value to a behavioral prediction after
all we're making predictions all the
time in the criminal justice system for
things like should we send this person
to prison or not if in prison should we
grant them parole or not questions like
that we're making these predictions now
when the question is can neuroscience
help us make those predictions more
accurately all right not necessarily
though with regard to lying or telling
the drugs not what I would imagine that
if you get somebody in a room and you
show them this 20 million dollar machine
or whatever they cost so we're now going
to stick you in here and tell you if
you're lying or not that might get a
confession that well mere polygraph
would want it no it says that was the
interesting thing the polygraph was very
effective for just that reason yeah
because people thought this was science
and it's going to in a sense tell the
truth about me so people would confess
even though in fact the polygraph is not
a very valid method of lie detection
well the legs knew Alan like this is all
really reassuring to know let's turn to
one of the the biggest problems in
criminal justice and probably this has
always been a problem and that's the
question of how how reliable is an
eyewitness we in our mock trial we had
them we had a store clerk who was
threatened by someone holding a gun in
his face and the question was where
you're paying attention to the gun or
were you really looking at the person
who was threatening you and the real
question is does he remember who fired
the shot take a look at this video so
how did you go from need a fire honey
and i have come to Stanford University
to see if we can use her brain to answer
the question can a brain scan the code
her memory
and tell whether or not she's seen a
face before native first looks at a set
of two hundred faces for just two
seconds per face and will my brain
remember things that I don't your brain
might remember things that you do i do
signatures of every new bonita you're
ready you're ready to go into the two i
am ready to go in oh good luck thank you
nita settles in for what will be over
two hours in the MRI machine while i get
to watch with the memory decoders
inventor stanford's anthony wagner and
she's going to have to decide for each
face on the screen while she's in the
scanner does she recognize it as a
patient recently seen yeah or is it
novel ok meet it so this is where we're
going to be collectively brain data of
whether you are remembering or whether
you're seeing a brand new face this time
nita again sees each space for just two
seconds then gets eight seconds to
decide if it's new or familiar meanwhile
the my ride is taking scans two seconds
apart are you looking into her brain
specifically focusing on certain areas
are you looking at patterns of activity
all over the brain for this study we're
looking at patterns of activity all over
the brain we could look in specific
areas but what we're doing is we're
looking at the pattern throughout the
brain every face she's encountering is
generating this complex pattern of
activity so does that mean that when she
recognizes the face that you seen before
consciously recognizes that that that's
a pattern that shows up pretty much
anytime she recognizes the face that she
seen before anytime is a strong
statement ok I were a lot of a lot of
the time yeah so the work that we've
done this far what we've shown is that
on average about eighty percent of the
time excellent we can accurately
classify an old face that's recognized
as old and distinguish that pattern from
a new face that's perceived as novel it
sounds like a fingerprint of recognition
not a fingerprint of a face but of
recognition that's that's right i think
what we are looking at
is neural the neural fingerprint or the
neural patterns associated with the
conscious experience of recognizing a
stimulus like a face that begins to
crack open the door anybody would be
tempted to use this anywhere in the room
with it exactly for an ordinary civilian
like me this seemed really interesting
and intriguing very attractive the idea
that if somebody recognized a face they
would you'd be able to know if they
recognize that face by scanning them and
that could give you information that
they wouldn't willingly give you if they
were giving testimony so that sounded
really great then I realized that
Anthony Wagner was teaching his subjects
how to defeat the experiment and make it
look like they were that they were
getting a record of something going on
in the brain that they weren't getting
that I bet Nancy I bet you really like
that that the researchers are taking
kind of a preemptive strike and learning
how these tests can be defeated what do
you think yeah I mean there's actually a
funny story about this in the late 1990s
I did an experiment on mental imagery
where had people close their eyes and
imagine a face or imagine a place and we
got such clear distinctive responses in
the brain different for imagining faces
and imagining places that we ran an
experiment where we categorized
individual trials and we could tell
eighty-three percent correct whether
somebody was imagining a face or a place
and when I got those data is the late
90s I thought oh my god if we publish
this some numbskull is going to think
that you can use this for lie detection
and so for months I was actually kind of
worried about this and I talked to my
boyfriend about a lot and all my friends
and I couldn't get anybody to worry
about it with me and I found that okay
I'll just publish it and if such
numbskulls come along I'll just have to
like you know publish other experiments
to see you know whether it could really
know whether it can be defeated and such
so I think aunt
experiment is a beautiful one it's
really nicely done it's actually
scientifically interesting as well but
it's defeatable not just by the counter
measures he's training his subjects to
use it's also worth pointing out that in
that experiment what he found is you
could tell however percent some
reasonable high percent accuracy whether
the face was familiar or not but
actually you could only tell whether the
subject thought it was familiar not
whether it actually was so it wasn't
that by looking at the brain you could
tell anything the subject couldn't tell
you yeah so it would only be useful for
compelling testimony not for discovering
something new and never need a fair
honey who did the test tell me she that
he was trying to determine if it was a
familiar face or something novel a novel
face that she was looking at on the
screen so when he showed her a familiar
face she looked at a bolt on the side
and the Machine and said wow what an
interesting novel boat both and and so
she was recognizing something novel and
I guess that showed up and defeated the
experiment but it makes it makes another
point which is that as Bob said
functional area is a magnificent tool
for understanding the human mind what a
fabulous enterprise it's thrilling it's
a terrible tool for the courtroom and
one of the reasons is that the signals
are very very noisy they're very messy
we have to work really hard to pull out
a signal that we can understand
scientifically and it's the easiest
thing in the world to defeat that signal
by either you know engaging in mental
arithmetic or just moving your head I
guess move your head a little bit in the
datas garbage what what's needed Stephen
to bring evidence like this into the
courtroom what what what kind of what
demands our [ __ ] well the Supreme Court
in a very influential decision Dalbert
has come up with the standards for
scientific evidence when scientific
evidence has reached a level of
sufficient validity that it can be
admitted into the courtroom so it looks
at things like has it been peer-reviewed
does it have a sufficiently well
established error rate has it been
accepted in the field but the
algorithm is very soft and it leaves
judges a great degree of discretion to
decide whether or not the scientific
evidence could come in in other
jurisdictions we have what's known as
the general acceptance test is it
generally accepted by experts in the
field and then you basically are just
doing a sociological survey so so to
speak of the experts the real question
however is not whether at a certain
point we might reach a level of
sufficient scientific validity to permit
admission the question would be would it
be an invasion of constitutional rights
to compel someone to undergo one of
these kinds of scans and even if it were
found constitutional which i think is
very doubtful then we'd have the problem
of countermeasures that Nancy and Bob
have talked about and of course what the
neuro scientists say is well we'll be
able to soon to get good neural markers
for people trying to use countermeasures
at which point we would have an arms
race because then there will be
countermeasures to the anti
countermeasures to the end encounter and
the next thing you know who knows but
this raises profound legal and ethical
questions that I don't think we're yet
ready to address because again the
science for these purposes isn't there
yet so you think you're doubtful that
compelling someone to take a test like
this whether or not it's effective is it
would be unconstitutional even if it's
effective it might be unconstitutional
one of the questions would be since the
Fifth Amendment guarantees us a right
not to be a witness against ourself and
it said to prevent testimonial
incrimination would basically looking at
a neuro marker that was a proxy for a
mental state kind of process would that
be compelled testimony or would it be
simply something like drawing blood to
see what we're giving up or your yeah
that's right I mean that if that can
place you at the scene of the crime
isn't your own DNA testifying against
you well we make a distinction and again
it's not a terrifically clear
distinction in all cases between
physical evidence and testimonial
evidence so the Supreme Court has said
as long as you don't
dooley invade a person's body you can do
physical tests like a breathalyzer or
young taking blood or something of the
sort but this is perilously close to
testimonial and one of the interesting
questions and it's not going to be a
scientific question it's going to be a
legal and philosophical question is this
the sort of thing that the Fifth
Amendment is meant to protect us against
it seems to me the beginner to know
everybody's notion about this this
occurred to me as you were just saying
that seems to me there were a couple of
kinds of information you can get out of
looking into somebody's head one is if
his brain is screwed up in some way and
you and you that that contributes to a
sense of a state of mind that he might
not be so culpable because of or you
watch him or her thinking and then
they're in the sense giving testimony
against themselves that's are they are
they separate issues or in what do you
think I think those are separate issues
whether someone has some kind of clear
brain pathology whether from lesion or
trauma or whatever I think that is
certainly the sort of thing that can be
medically well characterized then the
question would be what is the relation
between that particular form of brain
defect or central nervous system defect
to the legal question that we're
concerned with which is typically in the
criminal justice system what were the
person's actions and mental states and
unless the link was very very tight
between the two it's not clear what the
the brain evidence would be adding so
let me give you just a very simple
example suppose the defendant claimed
that he was in the midst of an epileptic
seizure when he seemingly assaulted
somebody the fact that we had good EEG
electroencephalographic evidence that
the person was subject to it was was
suffering from epilepsy since he wasn't
in the EEG at the time of the crime were
not sure but the fact that he clearly
diagnostically suffers from epilepsy
would be relevant the more interesting
question is when you're outside the
well-characterized medical or
neurological conditions and we're just
talking about other brain processes
whether or not we
they're abnormal what's the link to the
legally relevant behavior the accent
mental states that the criminal justice
is concerned with and that's the open
question that we hope in the future
we'll get good evidence for I just
knocked my microphone of my head I'm so
I'm sorry to excite you I don't know
what was going through my head when I
did you were nodding before when I was
trying to make that distinction but what
occurred to you commit their crimes
while in the MRI we have the state of
mind during the crime no Jasmine of
Anthony Wagner talked about getting
signals activation signals from all over
the brain what what can you explain what
he meant by that so it's just a
statistical measure where you're looking
you're not say just asking does this
brain area light up when the person is
lying or whatever looking at all the
different activity points in the brain
and looking for statistical correlations
between patterns of those activity
points and what the person's saying or
doing I mean it's it's not that
different than when Amazon tries to draw
statistical conclusions about what kind
of books you like by the kinds of books
you search for and by and so on every
time I do it you know I go in google and
google searches advertisements pop up
based on my way to grow a new google in
the quarter i figure out you for your
whole life from what books you buy so
told you get a pattern of all this
activity sounds like you need a very
sophisticated algorithm to to find any
meaning in that the more data you have
the better your algorithms will be hamid
on amazon does much better after you've
bought a few books yeah then yeah we're
the first time I different basing it on
one yes right exactly pee-yew you were
doing a similar experiment using an emmy
gee device right get what what is that
how does that work well the MIT is a
little bit different from the fMRI it
only provides signal for the cortical
surface and it has a greater temporal
resolution
and it provides a signal that's closer
to actual neuronal firing so the a.m is
magnetic right enemy yes so it's based
on electrical magnetic currents that
emerged from neuronal firing as opposed
to a fry which we also do which is an
indirect measure based on our blood
oxygenation changes due to neuronal
firing is it a similar kind of kind of
device you get inside a tube or how does
it work yes you you have to get you or
electrodes are placed on your head and
you put inside a machine that will
actually measure all the differences in
the brain that are occurring while
you're doing a task and in that sense
similar to an fMRI I mean as bob was
saying the whole brain is always working
but we're doing with these experiments
are finding relative differences in
manipulations that we think are focusing
on specific aspects of behavior and in
our studies in many of our studies we
get this data from looking at a large
group of individuals and that's where I
think that there is a very important
point to to think about of the
relationship to informing the law what
we're talking about individuals listen
to talk about that everybody should join
in on that was something that was new to
me news to me as we started doing this
because probably like a lot of people I
imagined that which something happens
here in my brain that everybody else in
this room will have something happen
right there and their brain when they're
going through a similar experience but
these studies are done as averages of
sometimes hundreds of people like I
understand and those averages include
different locations were similar
activations that right that is so
therefore is it difficult therefore to
take that average and apply it to an
individual right although we will
probably talk about this a little bit
later I think there are times when you
can characterize a certain group of
individuals for example juvenile's or so
for that might be informed
they you might be talking about that a
little bit later yeah okay but I just
wanted to add to that yet you can
analyze functional MRI data in different
ways in my lab pretty much everything we
do is analyze individual subjects in
great detail and the reason we do that
is precisely that the exact location of
those activations differ from subject to
subject so when you do a group analysis
you lose a lot of the exquisite fine
grained structure that's present in any
one individual and so it's a key
question with all of these uses of MRI
in courtrooms whether they apply to
individuals because you know legal
issues pretty much always applied to
individuals the Anthony Wagner study one
of the things that was impressive about
it was he actually showed in individual
subjects that that he could do that
discrimination whether the faces were
familiar or not that was one of the
things that was impressive about the
study of course it was foiled by
countermeasures but some of these
studies do work in it so it just did
clear this up for me for seconds in that
court I'm not really getting it what do
you get out of the averaging study that
you don't get out of the individual and
what do you get out of the individual
study that you don't get out of the
average okay so if your question is do
people in general have a particular
pattern of activation when they say
something false compared to true yeah
the most standard way to analyze that is
to line up a bunch of brains as best you
can and look across them and ask whether
there is something statistically
significant that's consistent across
those subjects then if it aligns well
enough you can detect that and that's a
standard group analysis that's the most
common thing to do and that's perfectly
legitimate but it that method often
loses a lot of the structure that's
available in individual subjects so it
is possible frequently to discover
things that you see in each subject
individually that just will never come
through and improve analysis so it's
just two different ways to look at your
yeah yeah
um what you get slim lead clear the
individuals there's so much variability
that sometimes you'll find individual
who's not generating when I was talking
or we say that again with individuals
what it's it's not something that is
reliable so you might find an individual
who is not showing the pattern that you
would have predicted yes so that that's
where it becomes a little bit more
difficult to use in something so so it
sounds like you're saying we have
evidence of an average of a number of
individuals now we're comparing this
individual to that average but the
individual let's say while lying or
recognizing a face is not having
activation that matches the average so
we might draw the wrong conclusion about
the individual is that roughly what
you're saying that's one way but also
you know in the approach of looking at
the individual and trying to predict
activity some individuals are just not
reliable in the scanner for a million
different reasons like they move too
much or they're asleep I mean there's
many reasons why one individuals the
problem is not unique to brain imaging
so take a simple example if you took 100
men and 100 women and average their
heights you can be pretty sure that
you're going to get a statistically
significant difference that the men will
be taller and that's a real result and
if this weren't obvious it would be
something you could publish but I if you
just say this person is 5 foot 6 are
they a man or a woman yeah no good right
okay so so so going so you can't mate
simple for me you can have legitimate
scientific result based on group
averages that tells you something about
differences on average but then when it
comes to taking those statistical
distributions that you've discover and
saying something that is reliable about
a particular individual you need a much
higher level of diagnostic and so it
sits there there are there issues here
that are specific to brain imaging but
some of it is just about using group
averages to say things about individuals
it's just a perfectly general diagnostic
prob
there there is one one further question
though which is if the question is is
this person in Group A or group B you
may not be able to say that with
certainty but given you have group data
and this person is a member of that
group what you can say is what's the
probability so with with Josh's example
someone's five six what's the
probability here or she is a male or a
female and that you can say and whether
that would be something that would be
legally useful as an interesting
question right although just as a note
the the state of that ability in
clinical neuroscience is not very good
for example you cannot tell by scanning
a subjects brain with emmy gee
functional MRIs structural scanning
every kind of imaging you want to do you
have beautiful data you can't tell if
that person has autism or not what I
mean the most basic things you can't
tell by the membrane so it's gonna be a
long time before these things our
diversity made Helen mayberg had a
recent paper we're getting the details
right she could tell by looking at
certain patterns who people who have
depression which ones are more likely to
benefit from cognitive behavioral
therapy versus certain kinds of drugs
and I don't remember the exact numbers
you can make a prediction about who
would benefit from rich kind of therapy
Henry and that was born out but I mean
well this is recently been published my
PS was done people who know the study
better done in a prospective way yeah I
don't know now the question would be
will it replicate when someone else
tries to do it in another laboratory
will it be a robust finding or not but
it sounds like a much safer prediction
to make than that this person deserves
life in prison because we but suppose
you were trying to make a decision about
whether or not this person is a fit
subject for a particular rehabilitation
program and these are expensive if the
person would succeed in rehabilitation
maybe we could release them sooner if
they're not going to succeed why waste
the money on them it might be a helpful
tool someday very far in the future
well let's look at the next slip in that
we in our fictional crime on the program
a convenience store is held up and while
the young man is holding the gun in the
face of the clerk the clerk's wife comes
in to the room from a door on the side
of the store the young man holding the
gun turned swiftly and fires the gun and
it bullet lands in her head and pretty
much puts her into a vegetative state
now the question is the question then
the trial is whether he shot
deliberately or impulsively and that
gets us into a whole other discussion
take a look as Judge Rakoff observed
impulsive this is a classic adolescent
trait was Jimmy's 18 year old brain
simply unable to control his recklessly
impulsive act so this is a testing room
here to find out how is somewhat older
brain can control its impulses I've come
to the University of Pittsburgh in the
lab of bail Luna yes it here but first
look at me so I can explain to you live
we're all going to do what we're testing
here are your eye movements and
specifically cicadas which is in fact
the fastest motor movement that the
human body can make the saccade just
means an eye ailment so what we're going
to do is in i'm going to show you a
fixation target just look at it olesen
it's going to go off in the lights going
to appear somewhere you don't know where
it is and what I want you to do is to
look to the opposite location so it
should be something like this you're
going to look at it a light will appear
you look the other way and let me assure
you monkeys are really good at this
tether your openx about 6 10 18 now I'm
gonna do great
well perhaps I'm not so great it's
proving surprisingly hard to drag my
eyes away from the light right you know
what this is like I feel like I'm the
boy in the story and when that yellow
light comes in on the left side of the
screen or the right side it's going to
feel like it's the clerk's wife coming
into the room and I can't help but turn
to it and shoot a glance at ER the
visual system the brain stem is all
wired up the attentional system to look
it's something their peers in the
environment that's what our brain wants
to do so in order for us to not do that
you have to engage executive regions
that will say even though you really
want to do that rest of the brain I have
a plan in executive regions and our plan
is not to look at that too it's it's a
way for us to be able to look at the
integrity of the brain to be able to
engage a plan and take over the
impulsive areas of the brain which is
something that develops with you know
throughout adolescence baya when we
filmed this over a year ago you were
doing work on looking at how emotional
arousal might make adolescents even more
impulsive how is that going that
research yeah we're still analyzing that
data but the hypothesis is that if you
increase arousal it'll undermine the
ability to engage the executive
processes that you need to prepare to
not look at that light but what is
arousal mean doesn't mean more than I
think it means
your mind what I assume that's a
technical term well the idea is that
there are subcortical regions in the
brain that you can increase their
activation with things like emotion or
expectation excitation and therefore
that will bias your behavior one way or
another so in this case we set it up so
that it could bias towards being them
what would be an example of a non
aroused state and an aroused the
comparison of those two um you being in
the room looking at the LA lights that
was a non arouse so I see since I wasn't
even paying you for joining this leave
my subjects to pay for them but for
example we do that same task we're in
certain trials we tell adolescents and
adults that if they do it correctly they
will get a monetary reward and when we
do that first of all we see that all son
adolescents can do this you mainly very
difficult task and just because now they
might be able to get a reward and second
we see that the way that they do this is
by increasing the circuitry that would
be needed to do this correctly to a
higher level than than adults need to do
so compressing the gas pedal going a
little bit overdrive because they want
to get that reward hmm what about this
what we've all observed we didn't need
scanning to tell us that teenagers are
very impulsive exactly why are they so
impulsive well first of all my my
favorite philosopher edmund husserl said
the one of the greatest things that
science can do is provide evidence for
the obvious and i think when it comes to
adolescent research that's very much the
case
yes we know adolescents are impulsive
well above what are you telling us that
we don't already know well we're
providing mechanisms possible mechanisms
of how this could be occurring with the
variability is across development of
course not all adolescents are sensation
seeking individuals although there seems
to be a trend across cultures and
species that there will be a peak in
whatever sensation seeking that you have
that will occur during adolescence that
can be very adaptive and so forth so on
so it's a time for them to try new
things it not be afraid of going into
new territory using new tools maybe but
what happened what's going on in the
brain that's allowing that to happen
well that's what we're trying to
understand a little bit better some of
the hypotheses are that there might be
no chemicals like dopamine which may be
peaking during late altered in
adolescence so that these are some of
the hypothesis that we're trying to find
evidence for in the animal world there's
already some animal models suggesting
this and we're trying to to see if
there's actually a more mechanistic
explanation for why we might sometimes
see using fMRI increased activity of
these regions like the ventral striatum
that has a lot of dopamine increasing
doing the adolescent period in
comparison to childhood and adulthood I
think did perhaps Steven you mentioned
before I have this in the back of my
head that at that point in their lives
they're looking for models I don't know
if this was in relation to going to jail
but is it true but let me just ask that
as a question is it true that
adolescents are more susceptible to to
the behavior of the mentoring of let's
say somebody in prison so if you send a
teenager to prison you're putting him
more at risk and if you send an older
person in terms of recidivism
III think that we don't need brain
science to know that I don't have the
evidence for it had in brain science me
again common sense and experiential e we
know that yes if for no other reason
that you have a longer period to live
but yes that is a time where you are
able to be more influenced by the
environment and I think that that's a
part that talks about rehabilitation in
the sense that brain science does
continuously find evidence that the
adolescent brain in many different
respects is not at the same level as an
adult brain inferring that there is
continued plasticity and the ability to
change so when does the average brain
mature in I mean we pick numbers like
1821 driver's licenses at 16 people
could get married in many states or some
states even before then what when do we
consider the average brain to mature we
don't really know of course on I think
with my colleagues we've often cited
with the auto insurance company which
looks at 25 as really reaching maturity
so we don't really know but of course
the closer you get into an older age so
that's a process of so-called
myelination where the sheath of the of
the white cabling is his getting
stronger and growing yes so myelination
continues to increase throughout the
lifespan but for example in the
hippocampus it will continue to increase
into the 60s mmm the newer evidence
using diffusion tensor imaging looking
at the integrity of white matter is
showing that there might be hierarchical
maturation of different pathways with
actually cognitive pathways reaching
adult levels within the adolescent
period
but those that support social emotional
processing continuing to mature perhaps
into the 20s or even 30s I love more
than what you what your teenage son said
to you when you told him you wait what
did you say why are you doing is why are
you behaving like yeah he was uh yeah he
was a young adolescent and um he had
been behaving badly I don't really even
remember what he was doing specifically
so I said you know I'll talk to them
about this tomorrow when he's calmed
down and we talk in the morning he's
like mom I'm really sorry but you of all
people should know I'm not fully
myelinated but then I told them in order
for you to Milan eight correctly I have
to tell you about the limits are Steven
have been two or three supreme court
decisions in the past few years that had
an effect on sentencing right yes of
teenage people people what under the age
of 18 under the age of eight changes
what can you put off what what's all
that about what would they decided the
question is whether adolescents as a
class are sufficiently less culpable
that under the Eighth Amendment cruel
and unusual punishment Clause they
should be punished somewhat less as a
class now this does not mean that they
are not responsible when they commit
crimes when they're under 18 it just
means in general on average there are
less responsible as a group so maybe
their punishment should be mitigated so
in the first of these three cases the
Supreme Court said categorically that in
fact no juvenile could be put to death
no matter for any crime and then in the
second and the kiss case did not cite
neuroscience in the second case they had
to decide whether people could be given
life in prison without the possibility
of parole for non-homicide crimes once
again the Supreme Court said
categorically you cannot do this to
juveniles you kind of give them life
imprisonment for without possibility of
parole for non-homicide crimes in that
case they did cite neuroscience but in a
very general way and it wasn't clear
that it was necessary
in the case in the third case they had
to decide whether you could give
adolescents life without the possibility
of parole for homicide crimes and here
the Supreme Court took a more
individualized new instead yes you can
do it but you have to have a real
showing that this individual kid
deserves it and there was a very strong
statement by some of the justices that
this would be extremely rare indeed this
case too did cite neuroscience in a very
general way but once again there's a
strong argument and this is
controversial there's a strong argument
that the neuroscience was not necessary
to decision in the case I mean after all
we've had a juvenile court in the United
States for over a hundred years the
common law of England previously has
treated juveniles differently for
centuries and centuries and centuries as
the supreme court said in the first case
adolescents are different everybody
knows that and that is true so one of
the interesting questions is what is the
brain science here adding we have two
groups of people let's say adults and
adolescents who are on average are
different in behavioral ways would it
surprise us that on average their brains
are different in certain ways it
wouldn't surprise us in the slightest
and the question is what does it really
add except to help us understand the
mechanism better but it doesn't
necessarily answer the question are they
responsible or just on the legal
question though it's very it's kind of
interesting as we speak in today's New
York Times was an editorial dealing with
the question of whether or not it should
be retroactive if you've already
sentence somewhat someone's already
undergoing a life sentence now this
decision comes down that you can't from
now on sentence kids to a life sentence
shouldn't it apply in common sense to
the people you've already sentenced well
you know as a moral matter probably it
shouldn't but as a legal matter the
question is when should retroactivity
govern and when should
and that's a very narrow and technical
legal question about which courts have
split if the issue is simply a moral
question you know we've decided kids
shouldn't get a particular sentence yeah
then the kids were already serving it
they shouldn't have gotten it either but
that still leaves the narrow legal
question of retroactivity open and it
your opinion that brain research won't
help resolve that question no because
the criteria for culpability in law are
not brain criteria they are behavioral
criteria and if we never had a scan if
we had no brain science whatsoever we
could have made the exact same decision
about juveniles that the Supreme Court
made and on the death penalty case that
insight the neuro signed to science they
didn't have to they cited the behavioral
science they cited common sense and that
was good enough and here's something
really worth noting yes kids are on
average more impulsive although worth
pointing out young men and young women
are differently impulsive and what we
also notices let's just take young males
who are typically more impulsive and
commit far more of the crimes holding
constant as I think we must the brain
development there are vastly different
crime rates in different places at
different times it's not just the brain
that's doing the work culture is doing a
lot of the work yes kids are more
influenced by peer pressure but the
kinds of case that you're using your
fictive case is much more likely to
happen in the u.s. than in a lot of
other developed countries bye bye see
you nodding would I nod to everything
that's my [ __ ] rest and I had 50 till
payday and I say I mean this whole using
neuroscience to make these arguments
such a slippery slope I meanest Eva said
and what's becoming as brain imaging and
brain measurement techniques become more
and more powerful it becomes easier and
easier to find statistical differences
between different groups I have no
differ
I have no expectation sorry I wouldn't
be surprised if Harvard professors had
different brains on average than MIT
professors are you know University of
Pennsylvania law professors I mean we're
getting better it better at finding
these differences but then what what
conclusion would you draw from that what
why would Steve get off him a crime
because he's part of a group that has a
different brain structure than me is it
some people will use these arguments in
a non-scientific way that that really
raises the question that most of the
scientists I've talked to in doing this
program love to raise which is the the
false notion that you can claim you're
innocent because your brain made you do
it that there seems to be a tremendous
resistance to that idea and yet there is
this question of state of mind or the
condition you're in I mean if you're
inebriated and you shoot somebody didn't
wouldn't have meant or you wouldn't have
done it if you were sober if that's
determined doesn't that have something
to do with your you aren't there there
are layers of culpability right now of
course there are layers of culpability
and what one can say is as the Supreme
Court has said in a case in the late
1990s if your mental state is affected
by the voluntary ingestion of alcohol
tough on you and now many states don't
take that position but one certainly
could even though you might not be as
rational or capable of rationality
because you're drunk if it's your own
fault for getting drunk the Supreme
Court said you know a state can exclude
the evidence but suppose you've got some
kind of brain condition that affects
your behavior then clearly that's
assuming you didn't put yourself in that
state lets say by taking a drug or
something of the sort then it's not your
fault that your behavior has been
affected but once again the criteria for
culpability our behavioral acts and
mental states if you are a rational
person and we judge that behaviorally I
don't care how bad your brain looks
you're a rational person and if you are
clearly out of touch with reality and
there's no question of malingering even
if we can't find a thing as Nancy
suggested on a brain scan you're out of
touch with reality and the law ought to
take that into account as one writer for
nature but it actions speak louder than
images for legal purposes mm-hmm actions
be gladder than images right right yes
I'm going to take the bait and good so
there are two general justifications for
for punishment in the legal system and
you might say morally and one class of
memorable utilitarian or
consequentialist which is about
producing good consequences in the
future deterring people from committing
crimes incapacitating people who are
dangerous perhaps rehabilitating people
noting that we're going to learn from
neuroscience is going to undermine those
justifications for punishment but
there's another justification which has
a long philosophical history and that's
retribution the idea that part of why we
punish some people say the primary
reason why we punish an auto punish is
simply to give people what they deserve
and I think that this is where
neuroscientific understanding a
mechanistic understanding of human
behavior really touches a nerve when we
find out that someone commits a crime
and then we find out that they have a
brain tumor we say oh it's not maybe
maybe it's not really his fault it's the
brain tumor now a brain term is a very
obvious thing that you can point to well
what if it's a gene that makes somebody
more likely to commit a crime they say
well you know statistically it makes
makes that person more likely we would
say we're not going to let you off well
what if I injected you with something
that had the exact same effect on your
brain as having this gene dozen people
who just naturally have it and as a
result our best guess is that you
wouldn't have committed that crime had
you not have the injection now we're
going to say well is that really your
fault I think it's it's possible that
when you understand behavior as a
mechanistic process it doesn't mean that
all of responsibility goes out the
window it doesn't mean there's never a
justification for punish her for
punishing people but the idea
sticking it to people just because they
deserve it as an end in itself my
personal view is that that aspect of our
punishment philosophy starts to wither
and that that's the i think part of the
deeper philosophical significance of our
emerging mechanistic neuroscientific
understanding of human behavior so it
sounds like you're saying to me that
there will be we will see more
mitigating considerations as we learn
more about the brain and as we can apply
that to an individual who's accused of
bad behavior is that what you're saying
I think that our feelings are going to
be mixed for a long time until we sort
them out and on the one hand we're
always going to recognize the practical
need for punishing people right and
that's never going to go away and so to
really think about this clearly I think
you have to separate those two
motivations for punishment which is not
something that we ordinarily do when we
just respond intuitively to to a case
but I do think that if we all you know
five centuries from now if we just grow
up with the just taking it for granted
that were essentially complex chemical
constructions and that everything we do
is caused by what happened the moment
before in the moment before and we are
part of this clockwork universe I I
think that that does change the way we
think about guilt and innocence and you
know you're kind of retributive justice
and the impulse to get retribution or
not even to get retribution but simply
to punish wrongdoing is a very
interesting question I wonder if any of
you are are up on this as I've I wanted
to interview parents fair in Switzerland
who has done Studies on this about the
the pleasure derived from punishing
people for infractions I believe I have
it right
that kind of if that those studies it
seems to me might throw light on the
other side of the legal system not who's
guilty how how should they be punished
but if that runs a monk among those of
us who are trying to get good behavior
to take place that desire to punish I
wonder brain studies could help write
that situation maybe help us reduce
overactive prosecutors an answer you or
shake I don't know I it's an interesting
question I like I really like what Josh
said I'm not sure those imaging studies
speak to it so just for anybody lesson
from the disease are studies where you
guys can fill me and if I don't get it
quite right it's Ernst fair and Tonya
singer and in others where they they
have first they show that they they have
brain signatures of pleasurable
experience and the ideas that if you
watch someone else suffering you watch
someone else feeling pain you generally
activate brain regions that are actively
you feel pain yourself that's a sort of
empathy response but if you have
previously played a game with this
person and they have cheated nastily
then when you are scanned while watching
them suffer pain then you activate
reward positive that's the basic line
it's true it's much more entertaining
great so it's the neuroscience of
schadenfreude I think that's very
interesting but I don't think it really
divides between this interesting
distinction you made that could be built
into humans either you know for this
broader kind of utilitarian kind of goal
or as part of the retribution basis
bieber's going to throw his neck out
you're shaking his head so vigorous how
do you think I mean first of all
retribution is not revenge I mean we all
have feelings about things like
wrongdoing in punishment but what we try
to do is clean up our feelings and give
them a good justifiable basis
retribution is just a theory that says
people should get what they deserve you
worked hard you've got a good grade you
deserve a reward
it's a common sort of reaction we have
across the board bloodlust is not
retribution and retribution need not be
tough you could be a tender retributive
asst that is you believe people should
get what they deserve but they should
get a lot less than we give them so for
instance for many of the same crimes
that we give extravagantly long
sentences our European allies give much
shorter sentences for the exact same
sorts of behavior alright so retribution
is not revenge Josh I think has made
what is a sociological observation
rather than an argument in favor of
getting rid of retribution what he said
is basically if we become convinced that
were just mechanisms as he once put it
very provocatively we are similarly
victims of neuronal circumstances then
our notion that people deserve anything
will wither away that might be true I
hope it won't be true it might be true
but the question is should it wither
away is it ever likely that we will
think of ourselves merely as victims of
neuronal circumstances and if we do
would we even be thinking about
something like punishment anymore as
opposed to simply controlling
beneficence or malevolent people well
the punishment is a moral concept
doesn't that raise the question of
whether or not punishment is an
appropriate response to behavior that's
a moral question yeah well it's both a
moral question at a practical question
yeah and it also might benefit from more
brain research but Josh you yeah III
disagree with Stephens characterization
every everybody agrees that we should
give people what they deserve in some
sense the question is what's our
standard for calibrating dessert now if
you're consequentialist you'll say well
what you deserve is the kind of
punishment that overall produces good
consequences across society but the idea
of retribution is punishment as an end
of in
self over and above the practical value
that it may have now what we have when
we're familiar with psychologically are
our feelings and I think as Nancy's
suggested I think this is right those
feelings evolved biologically and have
been tuned by culture probably because
punishment is useful because it has
practical effects but sometimes our
feelings outstrip the usefulness of the
feelings so take a familiar example why
does food taste good why is sex sexy
right I the reason why we're attracted
to certain things is because of the
value that they have but that doesn't
mean that there's a perfect match
between those things something can be
delicious and it can be poisoned right
or you can find someone or something
attractive and it's not necessarily good
for you to go for it I so the question
is not will we ever get rid of our
feelings that undergird both retribution
and that have a kind of practical
rationale behind them the question is
when we slow down when we stop and think
are we going to justify doing things in
terms of things other than just the
consequences so to give a parallel
example we've learned from 20th century
physics that space-time is curved now
when you're going through the grocery
store that doesn't mean you're thinking
about the curvature of space-time it
seems perfectly flatly Euclidean it
always will until we rewire our brains
but if you're going to send a rocket
ship into space then you need to take
into account the theory of general
relativity in the same way I have no
doubt that in our day-to-day personal
interactions we are going to consider
people responsible for what they do and
praise them for the good things they do
and sneer at them for the bad things
that they do but when it comes to
putting somebody to death the sort of i
think legal equivalent of sending a
rocket ship into space where the stakes
are really high then do we want to rope
be relying on those feelings or do we
want to think really just about the
consequences themselves i weld favor the
light then what what if as many people
claim the death penalty deters if it
what there's a death penalty no sir
don't go for it no I say I say we don't
go
bored because I say it is such an
infringement of human dignity without
regard to whether the consequences would
be good or bad that we simply shouldn't
do it even if we could show it perhaps
save some lives and it seems to me that
once you decide to go purely
consequential we don't want to turn this
into a philosophical discussion if you
move Josh's way you run into all the
familiar objections to consequentialism
how do we actually balance those costs
and benefits how do we know what's the
proper time frame till the heat death of
the universe till next year so there are
there are familiar problems with
consequentialism there are familiar
problems with you know retribution is an
end in itself what we know are both are
features of how we morally approach the
question of what should we do to people
when we're the state and they've done
wrong and I don't think either is going
to leave our moral vocabulary or our
practices I think someday we'll have
this conversation where both of you are
in scanners and we'll learn this
enormous amount more than from what
you're so there's gonna be a lot of
frontal activation in both of us I'll
tell you that I think this next clip has
some bearing on this one of the points
we try to make and brings on trial is is
that the insights neuroscience is
providing is how our brains work mostly
applying only to group averages which we
mentioned before and as we said tonight
someone who doesn't want to have their
brain scan can confuse the scan and take
a look at this Clippers I think it's
some of it bears on what we've been
talking about this question whether a
brain scam could ever truly plumb
someone's mind if they were out to
defeat it is central to whether
neuroscience will ever have a role in
the courtroom and making judgments about
individuals but the insights of
neuroscience into the teenage brain to
help explain why young people in general
can engage in foolish and dangerous acts
we saw from jegede studies that a brain
like Jimmy's is likely still to be in
completely wired up from Bay aluna that
a teenage brain is unready for the prep
work needed to avoid making split-second
mistakes especially in emotionally
charged situations and from Larry
Steinberg that reward centers in the
teenage brain can be put into high gear
when friends are around all of which
raises the question are we in danger of
saying that as far as culpability is
concerned that he's not really guilty as
brain made I'm doing um yeah and I I
think that's one of the more important
sort of debates about how neuroscience
can inform the law that you don't want
to get to the level of making the
separation of my brain made me do it and
not me that's why I'm always saying it
should never be the critical aspect of
the law which is an ethical issue it
should just be an informative piece as
many other informative pieces might be
so I don't think that we can sort of use
it as an excuse to not be accountable
but I think it can influence what we do
moving forward what sort of environment
they should be in that keeps society
safe but that the probably worse
imaginable would be to put them in with
other people that are older and
criminals because this is a Time in the
brain is looking for peers and modeling
to know what to do Josh you you
co-authored a book that had in its title
for the law neuroscience changes nothing
and everything what did you mean by that
well I that paper was really getting at
the issues that we've been going down
back and forth on here it's certainly I
won't defend the view that says my brain
made me do it implying that there's a me
that's
effort from the brain I mean that's just
a mistake and I think that's the mistake
that most neuroscientists really want to
make sure people don't make what I what
I will say to paraphrase what I said
before is is that when you understand
that ultimately every decision you make
is a function of mechanical processes in
your brain which are themselves
functions of prior mechanical processes
all the way going back to the Big Bang
that may have an effect on how you view
free choice and responsibility not that
it means that all of responsibility goes
out the window that punishment is never
justified but it might mean that some of
our practices are well they'll start to
seem counterproductive or even immoral
when we when we recognize that there
isn't a guilty or innocent soul in there
independent of I think it's very murky
is with regard to responsibility how
many of you here who are brain
scientists feel that we are in fact
capable of making choices about our
behavior and regardless of the impulses
that come up in our head regardless of
our experience our except in extreme
cases of mental illness or are we aren't
we capable of free choice or what p used
to be called free will still is I'm a
strong believer or not I think just I
mean it too baby i would put what josh
is saying in a different context look if
you look at our prisons they're filled
with people who are disadvantaged in so
many ways you know they've may have had
a you know an inadequate childhood they
suffer from low IQ they're filled with
people with mental illness many people
with addictions I mean many bad things
all of which are going to affect their
brains okay that should not bear on the
question of guilt or is innocence that
should not bear on these questions of
free will it should bear on our
questions of what do we do with all
these people just stick them in a cell
and do nothing
and then hope that you know 20 years
later they come out and they're cured I
mean it leads you towards better
treatment for the mentally ill that are
programs for people suffering from
addictions and so on and so on and so on
that's the way I think where we should
be putting our efforts on the
consequences in not on the guilt or
innocence and because then you're just
undermining our whole philosophical
system you're undermining everything
about how we think about human beings
when you start doing that it sounds like
it's actually bringing brain research
into that yes where it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be on this other end of of xq
c brain research provides an explanation
for our behavior it doesn't provide an
excuse for our behavior I think that's
the way of looking at it Nancy you were
shaking your head well just go saved a
lot a lot of what we're calling brain
research is really psychology research
right so in some cases actually looking
at brains and form some of these
questions we're talking about but an
awful lot of what we're talking about
for example of things Bob just mentioned
the effects of being born you know with
low SES or low IQ or fetal alcohol
syndrome or you name it these are things
we're actually behavioral studies will
be at least as informative I'd guess
probably more informative than anything
you can do looking at brain so just it's
sort of a clarification that we're using
brain science but really a lot of what
we're talking about is just psychology
babe what do you think they'll be mostly
responsible for what we do regardless
and I completely believe in free will
but you know that could be a religious
belief for all I know but um you know
when when I've had to think about this
and write about this with reference to
adolescence I I very much I think side
with what up and hearing here in the
sense that I've never felt comfortable
with informing the culpability aspect of
it and I've often been asked to be an
expert witness and I've always said no
because obviously the crime was
committed where I did feel that the type
of research that my colleagues and I do
could inform and I know that you know
psychological studies also show but I
think it gives it more strength
is the extent of sentencing and I was
involved in some of these supreme court
briefs where the sentence was the rest
of your life for a sixteen-year-old
obviously for many ethical reasons it
doesn't make sense but i think that the
brain science was able to give some more
weight to the psychological evidence by
saying look here we have real evidence
that the brain is changing and this
individual might be a different
individual 10 or 20 years not saying
slap their hands and let them go but
really focusing on the fact that perhaps
the rest of your life might be too long
and the rehabilitation might be in area
that we need to focus because the brain
is changing and you know check on them
10 20 or something years or or find ways
that you can psychologically or so forth
identify who has been rehabilitated
which we know very little about and I
think it would be an area that where we
could make some advances they could help
people we mentioned josh is writing on
this of you wrote a paper that got a lot
of attention called the brain over claim
syndrome yes you found a problem for
people with the brain research yeah I'm
in the great tradition of American
psychiatry of you know making up new
syndromes and suggesting them as
provisional what what often happened was
you know some of the advances in brain
science and neuroscience have done by
the people on this panel are stunning
it's fabulous science and I'm as
impressed as anybody with it the
question always is what's its actual
relevance to legal questions as opposed
to its rhetorical relevance you know the
pretty pictures are they convincing etc
etc and what I saw was a lot of people
made claims about legal relevance that
were simply far beyond what the science
had to offer and this was not in any way
a critique of the science because after
all
especially with fMRI it's a relatively
young science it's working on one of the
hardest problems there is in all of
science the relationship between the
brain the mind and action most of the
studies have not been done to address
legal questions so the fact that there
wasn't a lot yet that was relevant to
law was neither surprising nor upsetting
but people were nonetheless making
claims that were not justified and what
I said was basically curb your
irrational enthusiasm and tried to show
me precisely how this neuroscience
finding actually answers legal question
show me the chain of inference and if
you can't do that yet then fall silent
until you can that was the point now my
impression from most of the people I've
talked with the vast majority of people
I talked to his an avoidance of over
claiming they've gotten much better haha
because I recommended cognitive juro
therapy and I think many have taken the
course well so far I've been asking all
the question and you might have been
thinking I I have a question why isn't
he asking why don't you join the
conversation now the folks in the room
and and ask what you'd like of our panel
who's got a question we have we have
microphones so we'll hear you on the
video cameras in addition to in the room
I think you convinced everybody of both
sides of the argument anybody what's the
what's the constitution of the the crowd
tonight are you are you made up of
people from both brain science and and
the law the legal studies how many
people are schooled in brain science
tonight yeah whew how about the people
in the legal profession yeah more I
think
yes how many are here cuz your mash fans
good question yeah hey okay we saw no
questions yes okay good oh that's 10
sorry didn't see my question is have you
conducted research that basically
compares brain activity for an
individual that has committed a tort
intentionally or to show that they have
committed it through negligence and what
were the results if you have 00 take a
crybaby it's a good question but it'd be
a very hard study to do because what
would you do what you could I suppose
have the person think about what they
did think because of course you're
scanning them long after the event right
there may be as Bob said if you arrange
for everybody to commit their crimes in
a scanner that's a different ballpark
right but but most of the time that's
not the situation and so you'd be
scanning them way after so what would
you do well you could ask them to think
about the time when the event happened
but it just seems extremely unlikely to
me that you to get any signature of
intent way after the effect just trying
to think about it I don't know don't
guys disagree just hopeless there is no
study that addresses your question
directly the distinction you've drawn
between doing something on purpose and
doing and causing a result because you
were careless is also an important
distinction in criminal law if you kill
somebody on purpose it's a much worse
crime than if you kill them by being
careless so one of the things that I'm
engaged in now as part of research team
trying to determine if we can find a
neural signature that distinguishes
between knowing the result you're going
to cause and being consciously aware of
a risk that you're going to cause it and
it turns out to be as nancy has
suggested this is enormously difficult
to do even in a controlled laboratory
experiment to sort of set up the
research design so that you're clearly
distinguishing between these two mental
states in the stimulus and then seeing
if you can find the neural signature is
extraordinarily difficult to do and
we're in the midst of seeing if we can
do it I'll just add one little thing
which is this is less relevant to the
kind of court situation but there is a
magnificent result recently published by
Rebecca Saxe and jury cluster Hale who
are out here where they they show that
it's not that you can detect a signature
of intent versus accidental harm but you
can detect a signature brain distinction
in a person thinking about whether
someone else's actions harms were
intentional or accidental you can see
that different signature just when
you're thinking about someone else's
actions which is quite remarkable but it
doesn't help us in this immediate we
have a question over here thank you this
has been really interesting so the panel
discussed the problematic nature about
applying aggregated data to groups from
groups to individuals and I'm very
sympathetic to professor Morris his
qualification of that if we shift to
thinking of probabilities but I wanted
to push a little bit further so how was
comparing an individual to a standard
based on data from a group average
different from comparing that individual
to a legal standard like the reasonable
man which is appealed to to determine
the validity of a provocation defense in
some jurisdictions so if we think it's
acceptable to ask if a reasonable man
would have been provoked and if the
reasonable man would have done is the
defendant in this situation why can't we
ask whether the group average man would
have been provoked and whether the group
average man would have done as the
defendant did the analogy the question
the analogy is a good one but it is a
slightly different question if we ask
just as a statistical matter is this
person behaving or what's likelihood
that they're behaving as an average
person would that's a real statistical
question reasonable person standards in
law are not a statistical standard they
are a moral standard we're asking what
can we expect of each other and the
reasonable person in law is not a person
at the
50th percentile it's have you reached a
standard of what we expect of an
ordinary ethical citizen it's probably
if we were think of it statistically far
below the mean because after all half
the people in the population are below
the mean statistically and if the mean
were what we're required half the people
would not be responsible so the
reasonable person standard is actually a
relatively low standard in law and it's
not a statistical stand it's a moral
stand we're asking the jury to decide
under the circumstances what an ethical
person have behaved that way but when
you see how most people react if they're
someone's elected president it's clear
that there's no such thing as a
reasonable man when no calm had somebody
here thank yes I'm considering a present
judicial system where we have a jury of
persons peers we have to decide whether
the defendant is telling the truth and I
envision a situation in the future where
science has come to the point where you
put a defendant through an fMRI or
similar more maybe more sophisticated
skin and you find out that he is really
telling a lie and the truth is he's
guilty do we need the judicial system
would you comment well yeah if you feel
that the judicial system works and the
another thing doesn't right well yeah
look the judicial system proof beyond a
reasonable doubt in a criminal trial is
obviously not beyond all doubt where
human beings were fallible there are 12
people on the jury they talk and we hope
that their diversity and their wisdom
together will come to a decision that we
can be morally comfortable with although
we know there is a non-trivial chance
that they've gotten it wrong
now certain kinds of scientific
techniques can help make that decision
making more accurate I give you DNA and
that really helps us make decisions with
lie detection the interesting question
is whether or not we will be able to
compel somebody so for instance today in
the criminal justice system you can't
use the polygraph and this was even
before it became clear which polygraph
was as inaccurate as it is and there are
all sorts of constitutional questions
and ethical questions about why that
should be so what will happen if we get
so much better and so much more accurate
how will our legal system change in
response to that it would just simply be
a sociological speculation on my part
where we treat neural lie detection the
way we treat DNA or we treat it much
more like forcing someone to confess by
putting them under the rack and screwed
you have a question over here yeah so I
was thinking about maybe another trial
perhaps not a criminal trial where our
brains would be put because this kind of
scans sound to me like something that
workplaces would really love they were
able to stick you in the machine and in
an hour get a report that says that this
person is innovative and creative and
you can really do to work well but this
person not so much sounds to me like
this is something that people would
really love to use and it's also a legal
issue because it will bring all the you
know discrimination lawsuits etc so what
do you think about this kind of use have
you heard anything about interest in
this and and also I think it comes back
to what Professor Green was saying about
whether we can really be you know
distilled to these mechanical neurons
firing in our brain to be evaluated for
how well we
do or is there something you know what
are your responses to this that's it I
actually think that you can address this
issue without getting into the to the
dicey metaphysical stuff I there there
is no doubt that there will be things
about your brain that are measurable
that are correlated with behaviors of
interest and the question is simply how
i tore those correlations now how tight
will they be in the future and how much
of interest are those behaviors it
wouldn't surprise me if you could could
look in people's brains and make a
better than chance guess about whether
they be good at this or good at that and
there's some evidence for this so
there's this fantastic study done a few
years ago looking at London cab drivers
and the reason why they studied London
cab drivers is because they've been a
lot of work in rats running mazes so
there was a lot of neuroscience known
about navigation and memory for places
laid out in space and so who are the
king rafts of the human world it London
cabbies have this incredible map of all
of London in their heads and sure enough
they found that the London cavies had
bigger hippocampi important parts of the
brain widely studied in this building
than other people now it could be
because of their experience it could be
because of some kind of selection
pressure on them you got a big
hippocampus into the cab you go either
way the correlation was quite robust so
if you're running a cab company you
might get some traction already today
and it's just a question of what's
what's coming down the road I'm going to
largely disagree okay and that is that
London cab driver study is lovely we all
teach it in undergrad classes it's great
fun but the effect sizes are minuscule
and brain imaging studies are extremely
expensive and difficult to run they're
not practical I would submit that in a
10 minute behavioral tests that costs
approximately nothing she would learn a
whole lot more I don't disagree that's
that's one of the important points you
know when it's just for example in your
in your scenario when is it better to
just have a conversation with someone
and ask them and get the information and
when does neuroscience when is it able
to give you something that you were not
able to get at that point so for those
circumstances I can't I even thought
about it for a second like grad students
but but then I thought I get so much
more from having a really great
interview Kenny layers of references etc
so I think that that's something that we
really need to think about I'm not been
can we really add with neuroscience yeah
I'm not sure there's a single case I
can't think of a symphony swear if I
wanted to know something of real world
significance whether to admit a grad
student who's what's killed on what
anything that I would care about that I
would look at brain data over behavioral
data probably not a single case but if
you take lie detection and the standard
lie detector as though as a case point
the federal government is a huge loser
polygraphs companies many companies
doing polygraphs and the statistics are
that the polygraph is accurate about
seventy percent of the time for a lot of
businesses that's just fine if they make
thirty percent errors that's just fine
it's terrible but from their point of
view a sloppy inadequate method that's a
little bit better than chance increases
you're saying is they do a whole lot
better with behavioral measures right
you want implicit measures of what
people really think use Missouri and
panache ease I a t-test as many
behavioral tests that can tap into
implicit things they're probably all
more powerful and the real reason that
people use polygraphs is not because
they're going for that 70 sent seventy
percent predictability but for the
reason that Alan mentioned a while back
which is that when people are hooked up
to a polygraph they think they have to
tell the truth that's that's the real
reason they're still used that's what it
I sense a little consensus here and look
on the question of if you can actually
add value and it's good and if you can't
hold back everybody seems to being like
you would you agree oh yeah I agree the
question is there's just no law of
neuroscience that says neuroscientific
evidence can never add value to
behavioral evidence that may be true
across the board right now
but I have no doubt that there will come
a day where there's some kind of
neuroscientific test that when used to
supplement whatever behavioral evidence
we have ad somehow I get the impression
you leave the door open for that
possibility collapse absolutely and in
fact there's a recent study that's
legally relevant that it is worth
mentioning in this regard we talked
about predictions before we make
predictions all the time in the criminal
justice system and we have behavioral
measures for doing them some of which
are better validated than others the
question would be if we added a brain
scan would we get any value added and
making that prediction more accurate
until this year there has not been one
study that has addressed that question
directly prospectively the first study
was published in april i believe it was
of this year basically looking at arrest
records of people who had been scanned
and seeing whether anything on the scan
could predict five years out whether or
not they would recidivate and it turned
out that the effect size was very very
small and arrest records are not a
perfect measure and it didn't compare to
the very best behavioral measures but
nonetheless there was a statistically
significant increase in the predictive
ability of the researchers to predict
who would recidivate according to arrest
records five years out it's not nearly
ready for prime time but as far as I'm
concerned that's a really good
proof-of-concept study that shows how
neuroscience might some day in the
future when it's better replicated
better validated and remember again as
Nancy said these are incredibly
expensive things to do how much value
added do you need to start scanning
prisoners on recidivism so if you're
getting a tiny tiny effect is it worth
it but it is proof of concept I think we
have time for only one more question so
I apologize to those people waiting I
hope this is really good it's the last
how the pressures on
first of all I think of a discussion I
found it really fun and interesting to
hear throughout the discussion it seems
that we've touched on psychology and
neuroscience as well as philosophy and
given the evolution of these three
fields and legal studies as well given
the evolution of these fields they seem
to be merging quite interestingly and is
the future grad student or the future
undergrad student need to study both on
the moral implications of their
neuroscience or psychology as well as
neuroscience or the legal implications
all three of these things there's a lot
of interest and I even having classes
discussion groups and so on about the
moral implications of what we do the
ethical issues raised by what we do the
legal issues of what we do so I you've
cited what is really the current trend
which is in fact to educate neuro
scientists much more upbeat about these
sort of issues I don't know whether
there's a fair effort to educate the
lawyers oh there is that's good that's
good yeah no in fact courses in
quote-unquote neuro law are
proliferating there is a case book about
to come out a neuro law that's aimed at
law students we append have a program
where law students can get training in
neuroscience and so Bob is right there
is a lot of cross-disciplinary
fertilization and I think it's very
important that when we're talking about
public policy that the lawyers know
something about the neuroscience and
there are no scientists know something
about the law judicial college also
yearly invites people that have to do
the brain so the judges can better
understand how to take in this type of
information so I think there's a lot of
cross this and I think is from people
watch this program brains on trial
they'll see this conversation taking
place between neuro scientists and
people in the legal profession and all
of them concerned about both new
knowledge
and not hurting the justice system by
prematurely bringing in or allowing in
research that doesn't necessarily
provide value-added I want to thank the
panel for tonight I thank all of you for
watching I want to extend an invitation
to you to take a look at not only these
two programs on our website but ours
many hours of material that never made
it on the air and just as interesting
just as fascinating as the material it
did get on the air you can look at it on
at brains on trial com that's our
website where for instance you can find
Nancy telling us more about the limits
of fMRI Josh and his colleague Joe
Paxton doing the experiment with me on
how people choose whether or not to lie
extended conversations that I had with
both Josh and Steven and an experiment I
took part in it suggests my brain makes
decisions without my really knowing I'm
doing it which is pretty weird and right
now it's just me making the decision to
thank you all for coming and to the
McGovern Institute and to Bob DeSimone
for happiness thank you so much to swing
thank you all very much and also i want
to invite the audience that there's
coffee and cookies over here and there's
the literature on the McGovern Institute
sloan Foundation and the sloan
foundation for half of those cookies
thank you all thank you that was mr. oh
that was great